you know one of the things i've said
before and that i continue to say
many things i continue to say one is we
can have
political disagreements with our leaders
as we will inevitably
uh have while recognizing that some
leaders
are normal and others are not
and joe biden despite not doing nearly
everything i want him to do
has brought back a degree of respect to
the united states globally
that donald trump only ever dreamed of
and this has become
so clear during the recent g7
and nato summit and joe biden's
various meetings with world leaders
remember that under donald trump
world leaders were regularly visibly
annoyed with trump
endlessly frustrated with trump trump
was increasingly just not a part of
important conversations that world
leaders
were having the reporting from the g7
and nato is stunning how quickly
respect has been restored to the office
now that doesn't mean biden's a hero
i've said so many times let's not deify
politicians they're just people and
they're flawed people
they're really just like you and me it
doesn't mean
biden is a hero it's just a reminder of
how disastrous the four years
under donald trump were now first of all
statistically
before we get to the sort of anecdotal
stuff pew research center released a
report last week documenting
the huge improvement to the united
states stature
globally after the inauguration of joe
biden
and the portion of world citizens from
12 different countries with confidence
in the united states
in the u.s president went from 17
percent when trump left office
now to 75 these these are just stunning
numbers
this is basically a quadrupling
of the confidence in the american
president
in these early months of joe biden's
presidency compared to when donald trump
left office
the portion of citizens in these 12
countries with a favorable view of the
united states
has nearly doubled from 34 to 62 percent
already
so statistically when people like you
know the three people from the my pillow
rally say the us
is now uh you know the the we should be
ashamed now
the u.s is embarrassed globally no no no
no we we have the data pew research
center studies these
this noam chomsky referred to it a
couple weeks ago when we interviewed him
the favorable view of the us has nearly
doubled around the world under trump but
then anecdotally from the g7 and nato
politico describes it as quote overall
the g7 has delivered a significant win
for biden
while the leaders were panned for not
doing enough to vaccinate the world
and frequently fell short of consensus
on the toughest issues
they're definitely moving in the same
direction and other leaders
fell over themselves to welcome biden to
their table
when french president macron was asked
about whether the u s is back
as a global leader macron said
definitely
and later said it's great to have a u.s
president
part of the club and very willing to
cooperate
german chancellor angela merkel said to
reporters at the summit
quote being able to meet joe biden is
obviously important
because he stands for the commitment to
multilateralism
which we were missing in recent years
that's a direct shot at trump
even british prime minister boris
johnson who quite frankly
politically is an adversary of biden as
a right winger
boris johnson said he was quote
absolutely thrilled to see biden
and that speaking to biden was quote a
brush breath of fresh air
heather conley who served as a deputy
assistant secretary of state
to bush cheney's administration said to
politico quote there is no longer a
feeling of complete complete dread
before a nato or g7 summit
or fearing that the meetings would upend
u.s policy
a washington post report added biden was
greeted with delight by g7 leaders
relieved that trump's tantrums
will be replaced by biden's backslapping
so let me say it again
we do not worship politicians on this
show biden is a very flawed politician
and at the end of the day he's just a
person but to deny the clear difference
here is to ignore reality now
obviously and predictably people on the
right are saying
we now are globally embarrassed that's
not backed up by the data but what is
really sad is to see even people on the
left
who see biden not just as not
progressive enough
but who want to go further and they want
to pretend that we don't have a night
and day difference from what we had
under trump guys
it's okay to recognize and still to say
biden hasn't done enough biden's not
progressive enough
biden may not achieve the things we want
him to that's fine
it's okay to say trump was a reality tv
freak show
and biden is a respectful educated
diplomat and that's a really good thing
but we still hold biden accountable on
policy it's okay to do that
but the leftists who react to this by
saying
of course merkel and boris johnson like
biden they're all the same center-right
neo-liberal or whatever um
biden's policy platform
is not that of merkel it is not that of
johnson will he achieve everything he
said he was going to no of course not
and we'll hold them accountable won't be
critical
but we really participate
in a sort of collective gaslighting if
we and by we i mean others i'm not doing
this if we pretend
that there's no night and day difference
between what trump was
and what president biden is today uh you
know the the thing trump could never buy
no matter how much he spent and no
matter how much money he had
was class and professionalism and
maturity
and uh uh tact and diplomacy and
that doesn't make biden a progressive
hero
by its very by merely being that way
um but it changes dramatically the
standing of the united states
around the world and that's a really
important thing